no les parece que todo ello sea
inventado o bien una serie para un museo
o una exposición de arte o leen un libro
y se preguntan de dónde sacaron esa idea
o por qué no se me ocurre a mí les pasó
a mí me pasa todo el tiempo
hay gente que piensa que hacer una obra
la que sea es como soplar y hacer
botellas que a los artistas se nos da
muy bien la inspiración y la
originalidad pero son conceptos muy
amplios no como los definirían ustedes
como algo con lo que se nace pues por el
contrario algo que se construye o es más
bien con un bombillo que se prende y se
apaga cuando se enciende gritamos sobre
acá y todo está resuelto
yo entré a la escuela de cine en el año
cinco años después tengo un pie más
afuera que adentro
sin embargo
mi viaje por la escuela de cine fue un
poco accidentado literal y
figurativamente porque estrelló un carro
pero no voy a hablar de eso hoy
la escuela de cine para mí
fue
una montaña rusa
entre con muchos sueños y muchas
expectativas
era el mundo del cine actores luces
cámara acción boda el amor
y me basto solamente una semana
para darme bruces con la realidad y
darme cuenta que tal vez no era así
pasaban los semestres y yo realmente
no sabía si este era mi lugar
a decir verdad
no sé muy bien cómo funciona una cámara
y tampoco sé muy bien usar los equipos
de sonido o las luces y tampoco se me da
muy bien escribir guiones
realmente no sé por qué escogí la
carrera que escogí
veía a mis compañeros
sus talentos
esas historias tan maravillosas que se
les ocurrían estos proyectos tan
extraordinarios que tenían en mente y yo
me sentía muy mal
porque yo sentía que no podía hacer lo
mismo a mí me faltaba algo sentía que me
faltaba inspiración y sin embargo
sentía que los cortos que hacíamos eran
muy snobs con todo respeto a mis
compañeros había algo en esas historias
que no terminaba encajar
tal vez podría ser un factor de
originalidad nosotros estamos tratando
de ser otra cosa estamos imitando las
formas de hacer tal vez de otros países
no estábamos siendo nosotros mismos
en sus semestres me generaron una
aversión terrible a mi carrera
yo estaba en una dicotomía que no me
deja dormir en las noches o soltar la
toalla e irme una carrera donde tal vez
me sentiría más cómoda o dejarme llevar
por mi orgullo y mi terquedad y decirme
a mí misma a mí nadie ni nada me va a
ganar y yo lo que empiezo lo termino
después me gano el orgullo
estos semestres de ficción en la escuela
de cine
fueron difíciles y luego estos semestres
si un semestre documental
este semestre es como la oportunidad de
hacer algo uno solo pero yo estaba muy
abrumado porque no sabía qué historia
podía contar que tal vez le interesará a
otro
eventualmente encontré esa historia pero
antes quisiera como hablar un poco del
mundo maravilloso de las ideas
las ideas no se generan por generación
espontánea en el vacío ni nacen
mágicamente ni tampoco son un bombillo
que se prende y se apaga cuando quiere
las días más bien se generan a partir de
las historias de las experiencias que
vivimos de las relaciones
interpersonales que construimos todo eso
son elementos que nos comienzan a dar
diferentes perspectivas de una misma
cosa cuando uno tiene diferentes
perspectivas o puede mirar desde varios
puntos de vista una misma cosa puede ser
una vía para poder hacer algo
maravilloso
tal vez verlo desde un ángulo del cual
nadie lo había notado antes y puede ser
una vía para tal vez hacer algo que
nosotros llamamos original
hablando un día con mis compañeros yo en
mi crisis de no saber qué quería hacer
terminamos hablando de nuestras familias
yo les conté que yo tengo una tía que
decidió enclaustrarse en la casa
voluntariamente y que ha borrado su
imagen de las fotos de los álbumes
familiares durante todos estos años más
o menos 43 o 45 años
y mis compañeros se quedan sorprendidos
con esa historia y yo en plan pues
normal no pues todo el mundo tiene una
tía que esa silla
resulta que no ellos me dijeron ahí
tienes el tema de tu documental y sí
ahí estaba siempre estuvo enfrente mío
pero yo nunca lo vi me di cuenta que esa
historia tan cercana tan personal tan
familiar era una historia que
genuinamente la gente quería escuchar
pero yo lo había echado en saco roto
pensando que no le iba a interesar a
nadie
la inspiración siempre está en frente
tuyo no hay necesidad de ir a buscarla
lejos se nos ha hecho creer que la
inspiración es algo muy difícil de
encontrar que solamente las grandes
mentes las mentes brillantes son las
únicas que pueden tener ese privilegio
ese acceso
sin embargo no es así
todos podemos encontrarla lo que pasa es
que hay que ser un poco más observadores
hay que poner atención en los detalles
de la vida cotidiana
porque la inspiración y la originalidad
van de la mano se alimentan mutuamente
piénsenlo como semillas no
de una conversación de una experiencia
de una
situación cotidiana como pelar papas
comer de una manzana puede salir una
idea maravillosa solo hay que prestar un
poco más de atención
la historia de mi tía me permitió hacer
eso me permitió ver
una cosa que he hecho había conocido
toda mi vida pero verla diferente con
otros ojos
y me permitió conocer otras realidades
familiares que tal vez se estaban
escondidas un poco para mí
y me permitió también acercarme más a
ellos
una historia particular es siempre una
historia universal como humanos nosotros
compartimos los mismos sentimientos las
mismas emociones por eso cuando yo le
hablo a alguien más sobre amor sobre
felicidad sobre tristeza sobre
decepciones ellos me van a responder a
mí con sus propias historias porque se
refleja se reconocen en mí yo me
convierto en un espejo para ellos para
que ellos puedan interiorizar las
emociones de las cuales yo les estoy
hablando y las aplican a su vida no se
llama empatía
y empatía es lo que tenemos que tener
sobre todo en estos tiempos tan
difíciles
durante buena parte de mi vida o tal vez
durante los últimos cinco años cuatro
años más o menos yo
trate de ser alguien más traté de
ponerme en los zapatos de otro
fingí gustos ting y ser alguien que no
era
para agradar
y a pesar de que me trajo muchos
problemas hacer eso bueno tal vez me
atraiga donde estoy
todos hemos escuchado la frase pongas en
los zapatos del otro
que no la dicen un poco en regaños
cuando no somos empáticos con alguien
más
pero a pesar de que uno tiene que
ponerse en los zapatos del otro
también hay que comenzar a mirar
nuestros propios
a veces pensamos que hay algo que nos
falta
a veces pensamos que tenemos que irnos
lejos a buscar algo una pieza faltante
que no sabemos cómo se ven y que es pero
que sentimos que nos falta y entonces
nos vamos lejos como si esa pieza que
nos faltase encontrar en la mitad de un
bosque yo no lo pienso tanto así
siento que eso que nos falta está
siempre al frente de nosotros solamente
hay que poner un poco más de atención y
mirar un poco más a nuestros zapatos
muchas veces